RETO MEIER: Using
instant run is as
simple as pressing Run or
Debug with the lightning
bolt displayed, after
making incremental changes
since your last
build and deploy.
When something's
simple and helpful,
most people are
satisfied with that.
Hey, Wayne.
WAYNE: Hey.
RETO MEIER: Here you go.
WAYNE: Oh, what's that?
RETO MEIER: It's an
automatic dog feeder.
It makes it faster and
easier to feed your pets.
WAYNE: Hmm, nice, nice.
RETO MEIER: But we're engineers.
We're not normal people.
Uhh, Wayne?
WAYNE: Oh, hey.
Yeah.
I think I understand
the mechanism for this
and I think I know
how it works now.
RETO MEIER: Huh.
So let's take a look under
the hood of Instant Run
and see how it actually works.
I'm Reto Meier.
This is an Android
Tool Time Deep Dive.
And this is Instant Run.
Instant Run minimizes the
time taken to build and deploy
incremental changes to your
app when you run the debug
variant of your project.
Rather than doing a full
build, stopping the app,
re-installing, and
then relaunching it,
Instant Run tries to only
deploy changes, avoid
restarting or
reinstalling the app,
or even restarting the activity.
There are three variations
to Instant Run--
a hot, warm, or cold swap.
Understanding what
does happen and why
will help you take full
advantage of Instant
Run and to understand
its limitations
and how your code
changes affect it.
This is a very simplified look
at the Android build process.
Your manifest files are
merged and packaged along
with your apps
resources into an APK.
Similarly, the Java files
are compiled into bicode
and then converted
to DEX files that
are also included in the APK.
First, it adds bicode
instrumentation
to your class files so we
can replace code on the fly
when we update it later.
And it adds a new
app server class
that will run within your
debug app in which the IDE will
be used to transmit
code changes that
will be applied at runtime.
Gradle also modifies
the application
manifest to inject a
new application class.
This will proxy your own
custom application class,
if you are using one, and
injects custom class loaders
that allow us to apply the
real time code changes.
From now on, when you
hit Run Android Studio
checks if there is an open
socket to a server running
within your app and,
if so, uses that socket
to confirm that this is
an Instant Run enabled
version of your app running in
the foreground of that target
device.
It will then check
the app's build
ID to make sure it's
the version it expects
before sending any changes.
While you're developing,
Android Studio
monitors which files have
changed and, based on that,
runs a custom Gradle task that
creates a DEX file for only
the changed classes.
That new DEX file is picked
up by Android Studio which
deploys it to the app server we
injected into the running app.
The app server uses the custom
class loaders to load and apply
the updated classes.
But, of course, the old
versions of those classes
already exist in the running
instance of your app.
So Gradle has transformed the
updated versions to override
the preexisting classes.
The app server then
uses the instrumentation
that we injected into
our original classes
to delegate each method call
to the new override classes
that we've just loaded.
From now on, each time
the affected method
gets called anywhere within
our app, the new modified
version of the method
will get called instead.
If you set breakpoints or
look at your stack trace,
you'll actually see the override
named classes, methods called,
within your stack.
OK, so that takes
care of our hot swap.
So when do we need to warm swap?
And what is a warm swap?
A warm swap restarts
the activity.
When we do things like
changing resources,
the restart is needed to
reload the affected resources.
Right now that means
changing any resource results
in all of them being
repackaged and resent.
But we're working on an
incremental packager that
will only package and
deploy changed resources.
That said, warm swap
won't work for changes
to resources that are referenced
within the manifest or changes
to the manifest itself.
That's because the values
read from the manifest
are determined when
the APK is installed.
So you need a reinstallation
before those changes
can be seen.
So changing the string resource
used to define the app name
or drawable representing
the app icon
aren't supported
within Instant Run.
So far we've looked at warm
swap, stopped at resources,
and, before that, hot
swaps that override methods
within your running app.
But what about
structural changes that
can't be applied simply
by calling a method again,
like adding, removing, or
changing annotations, fields,
static or instant
method signatures,
or changing parent classes
or static initializers?
These cases require an
application restart using,
where possible, a cold swap.
Cold swaps supply code changes
by sending new DEX files that
are small slices containing
only the effective classes
to the target device
before restarting the app.
As a result, cold swaps depend
on an app loading multiple DEX
files.
So that requires
ART, which is only
guaranteed available on devices
running Android 5.0 or API
level 21 or higher.
The target devices running
API level 20 or lower,
and possibly using
the Delphic runtime,
Android Studio
deploys a full APK.
Instant Run tries to be clever.
But it can't turn back time.
If you make code changes
that affect initializers
that will run when the
application was first started,
you'll need to restart your app
for the changes to take effect.
To perform an incremental
build and restart the app,
click Rerun.
If you want to stop everything
and redeploy a clean build,
select Run and then
Clean and Rerun App.
To stop the running app,
perform a clean build and deploy
a new APK to the target device.
So is knowing how it works
enough for an engineer?
Let's check in with Wayne.
WAYNE: I've replaced the
mechanism with a Brillo board.
I think I can make this
thing internet-enabled.
RETO MEIER: That's
what I thought.
In that spirit,
let's look at ways
you can tweak your
use of Instant Run
to get the absolute
most out of it.
Instant Run is controlled
by Android Studios.
So you need to start and
restart your debug instance
from the IDE.
Don't start and restart your
app from the device or emulator
or things will get out
of whack really quickly.
Let's start by
improving those full
build times by tweaking the
resources allocated to DEX.
You can edit your project's
Gradle or properties file
to increase the maximum heap
size of the Gradle daemon
to enable DEX in process.
The default here is 1 gig.
So set it to at least
2, index and process
will be enabled allowing
multiple DEX processes
to run within a single VM
that's also shared with Gradle
and significantly
increases build speeds.
If you've increased the Java max
heap size in your module level
build.gradle file from
the default of 1 gig,
you'll need to increase the
Gradle daemon to the end size
accordingly.
Thanks to support in ART
for multiple DEX loading,
you'll get the best
performance of Instant Run
by setting your mean SDK
version to 21 or higher.
If your app supports
earlier platform versions,
it may be worth creating
a new product flavor that
sets your min SDK to 21
for your debugging cycles,
so you can take full advantage
of the enhanced Instant Run
support.
Also remember that any
changes to the manifest
will necessitate a full
build and deploy cycle.
So if your build
process automatically
updates any part of the
app manifest, for example,
automatically iterating
version code or version name,
consider disabling those
automatic updates in your debug
build variance.
Instant Run currently only
instruments the main process.
So if your app uses
multiple processes,
hot and warm swaps on
those other processes
will degrade to cold
swaps, or full builds,
if you're targeting an
API level less than 21.
Remember that hot swapping
doesn't re-initialize objects,
rerun class
initializers, or modify
data that's already been
saved or transferred,
anything that has already
run and won't be rerun
without the app restarting.
It's not always possible
for Android Studio
to know when that happens.
So remember to
restart your activity,
or restart the
app, when you know
your changes will require it.
If you're on
Windows, you may find
that Windows Defender
real-time protection is
causing Instant Run slowdowns.
You can get around that by
adding your project folder
to the list of Windows
Defender exclusions.
As of this recording,
Instant Run
doesn't support Jack,
instrumentation tests,
or deploying to multiple
devices simultaneously.
But Instant Run is
constantly evolving
with the team exploring
new techniques
to maximize the number of cases
that allow for a hot swap,
and minimizing the need for
cold swaps or full deploy
and install cycles.
And you can always find
the latest tips and tricks
on optimizing Instant Run on the
Android Studio documentation.
You can also explore
the cutting edge
by subscribing to the Canary
or Beta Release channels.
If you're having trouble with
Instant Run or any Android
studio features, let us
know on Twitter or Google+.
I'm Reto Meier, and this has
been an Android Tool Time
Instant Run Deep Dive.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
WAYNE: Yeah!